does somebody win the 1.9 billion
million two people some one person two
billion in L.A lottery yeah no uh
Powerball oh wow oh there was somebody
won in La yeah I didn't buy the ticket
or one ticket at least that's great you
know what's crazy about it they're gonna
actually get a billion dollars they're
gonna be a billion you know what they
can get so as they were breaking down
the KTLA this morning shout out to uh uh
Dallas Diamond Reigns um the weatherman
but they uh
you can take a one-time lump sum of nine
it's like 980 million or you can get
this like 1.4 million no nobody said 20
years nobody says to do that everybody
says get the lump sum yeah every every
every like 900 million dollars all good
yeah I'm not saying hey okay so here are
the those are the options here are the
options so on one hand the option is you
get 900 million I'll take that one oh
okay
it's actually probably going to be more
because of the people that bought it was
1.9 but it grew to two so it's going to
be an actual billion dollars but you
know all this does is just add to the
pop for taxes in California for them
yeah but who cares at that point if
you're paying a billion dollars in taxes
it doesn't matter if you guys think
about people bought tickets too many
people bought tickets that's all it goes
to taxes what helps to school
portion of it goes to schools it's fine
oh does it yeah prove it oh like the
ghosts exactly you believe all the wrong
yeah how do I move the wrong [ __ ] you
believe in ghosts but you don't believe
it like even if like 10 goes to schools
is helping I know and this guy's like
yeah but ghosts
they're [ __ ] our Mouse